warning the entire city of Tokyo is
currently under monster attack number
973 if you're still stupid enough to be
standing in the streets what the hell
are you doing run run for your life
hi father who is this it's your son oh
that's right I have a son how's your
mother doing she's dead
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha that's
hilarious
ha ha ha ha she was young too father
don't be a dick Shinji I thought you
needed me for something oh yes what did
I need you for something about an attack
it's probably nothing get your act
together Shinji the Angels are attacking
Humanity is in danger your dad's waiting
for you and we're getting the hell out
of here
what are you whining already but I
haven't even said anything I'm checking
it get the gun dad are you sure you can
get away from all the flagships
don't you worry I may not look it but
I'm an excellent driver
[ __ ]
[Music]
they feel detected an analysis powder
confirmed blue it's an angel well no
[ __ ] Sherlock
soon after 15 years the Angels have
finally returned angels you mean it's
not Godzilla attacking us again sir
godson is a fictional monster liar what
other possible monster could be
attacking Tokyo right now her no sir see
15 years ago during the second impacted
oh my god is Godzilla monster is giving
us hell please advise us on how to act
okay I got this copper unit circle
around the monster making yourselves
look as dangerous with a group of
turning butterflies tank battalion
resumed a bartlesville far distance like
the [ __ ] you are our support continue
causing as much collateral damage to the
city as possible without actually
hitting the target Delta team take your
pants off and start pressing around like
ballerinas do you know what you've just
done
not a clue come on this is Delta team
ballerina dances ineffective well I'm
stuck oi you two you got any ideas
perhaps it'll be going better fly guy
got off the phone no I said a large
pepperoni with extra cheese what do you
mean you don't deliver here anything
else
I suggest we fall back for now and come
up with that strategy before we do
anything snoop the [ __ ] sir you do
know the thing has an 18 field
Godzilla never had an 80 field you do
know what an 80 field is right sir
you're not even listening to me are you
say what now we have a visual of the
target patching it through now well [ __ ]
a duck are you even authorized to be
here it looks like you were right about
that ad Field 80 field thankfully no one
important got caught in that blast
what's going on don't worry it's just a
little nuclear explosion Oh what
no one at all how the hell did we
survive that
oh I'm sure people live through massive
doses of gamma radiation all the time
but how do we survive a nuclear
explosion by hiding in a car it doesn't
even make any sense we survive because
shops jayjay gentlemen we have exhausted
all resources and are out of ideas so
buy proper military protocol all power
now is transferred to the next biggest
douchebag bitchin wait a minute who are
you calling a douchebag you I dare you
to say that again you're a douchebag
that's what she said whoo [ __ ] what your
mom your mom who your mom who is with me
last night you mean your mom who's with
me last night no I mean your grandma who
was with me last night I'm surrounded by
idiots yeah well your mama's so fat when
she fell in love she broke it I don't
even know how the human race has
survived for this long now all that's
left is to get that son of mine he
should be here soon sir we've sent our
best driver to pick him up can you not
drive in a straight line sorry about
that
the names Masato and I'm here to welcome
you to nerd what's the nerve here read
this top secret information pack are you
sure I can read this did you get the key
card your dad sent you yeah I did I
messed it up a bit though so I hope it
doesn't matter
oh I'm sure everything will be fine by
the way can I have my picture back now
what picture you know that picture I
sent to you for a reference
Misato huh I wonder what I'm supposed to
do with this picture where'd all this
yogurt come from and why does it smell
weird and that's how I lost my virginity
Shinji I'm pretty sure you're still a
virgin
what do you mean well you kind of need
another woman to lose your virginity but
father told me that's how it happens so
what happened when a boy his right hand
love each other very very much yeah
that's fine I think I've heard enough so
my father works here does he oh so you
know what your dad does not really
neither does anyone else around here
someone get me a sandwich uh lunch times
in two hours damn it shouldn't we be
more concerned about the Angels right
now fear not things may look dire but I
have a master plan that cannot possibly
fail you mean you're gonna use your
whiny [ __ ] a son who's never had a
backbone his entire life to pilot a
giant robot he's never seen or heard of
before having no bride combat experience
to fight one of the greatest threats
mankind has ever faced
we'll have you put it like that anything
will sound stupid Oh
Rancic Oh what are you doing here you're
late I thought you were meant to be in
the control room well as head scientist
and nerve it's my job to randomly stand
around stripping in front of the AVA why
do giant robots make me so hot is that
really what you do well is it still your
job to randomly seduce young boys no so
this is the third child looks like a
little [ __ ] to me he is a bit sometime
definitely a [ __ ]
I mean this one time while I was driving
away from an angel he was screaming so
loud like a little bit look guys I'm
standing right here you know
don't be a dick Shinji are you sure this
time of your son will work of course I
am
what could possibly go wrong Shinji dad
pilot this robot no [ __ ] well there goes
that plan wait a minute I have the
perfect idea get in the damn robot
Shinji genius why are you always
shouting at me why why my wife is dead
the world is coming to an end and to top
it off I have a spineless [ __ ] son with
a bigger vagina than Justin Bieber who
was so useless he's incapable of even
thinking for himself was that an insult
no it was a compliment thank you what
Shinji you have to do it the whole world
depends on you but why me because only
children can pilot the giant robot why
is that why yeah why it's a [ __ ]
anime that's why the pilots are always
worried little [ __ ] children this is
getting us nowhere oh yeah dookey yes
sir commence operation get eugenia pilot
the AVA by using an injured ray to make
him feel guilty I mean operation to kill
Tripp sir
damn it no one can remember that name
yes ray you still crippled and [ __ ] son
of a [ __ ] wait is it just me or does
that girl kind of look like mother now
I've probably just my imagination
are you okay
shitty don't you get it if you don't get
that robot now still have to take your
place what's run away they must run away
I mustn't run flee they mustn't run away
every mustn't run away I mustn't run
away runaway train we hope you have a
pleasant journey
she gave you're listening to my tape
stop running away no I'm only gonna say
this once so listen carefully Shinji
right joystick for directions let's take
controls evasive maneuvers right trigger
to shoot electric of your secondary
weather and walk by leaning forward
decelerating by leaning back here's your
foot pedals to run the top control panel
is used to do a barel when in case you
get stuck the ejection password is 5 5
GI yr7 LG did you get all that wait wha
ok Shinji don't worry about that angel
staring right at you take it slowly and
start by trying to walk just remember
whatever you do be sure not the bus well
we're boned bone bound I have a boner
where's my damn sandwich I thought it
was lunchtime already sir I think we
have more pressing matters at hand what
could be more important than my sandwich
what about Shinji sir Shinji 1 now your
son sir oh I'm sure he's doing fine
someone get me my sandwich emergency the
Aven Gillian is in critical condition
the skull has been pierced what's the
status of the pilots it's currently
passed out in the AVA also it seemed
like some of the LCL inside has been
replaced with urine figures the
Evangelion isn't responding to the
microwave frequency controls check the
synchronization rate the 810 cm
synchronization reads inverting the
pulse is reversing you what no have you
tried breaking the circuit negative the
circuit breakers are working the signals
being rejected by the neural network
what the hell are you guys talking about
come on Monica seal is on receiving and
reach residents are Mike what am i
analysis just come in it's cold red but
resident in the third order harmonics
can only mean one thing Evangelion is go
berserk cuz I the only one who has no
idea what the [ __ ] you're saying what do
you mean it's golfers are
one is activated its own 18 field is
utilizes the faith-based will your
cervix
that was a damn good sandwich sir the
angel has just been destroyed what just
happened
it looks like the angel she suicided
into a giant cross why the hell would it
do that maybe it has something to do
with angels genetic makeup that gives
its death this particular shape or maybe
the angels are actually messages from
God or maybe this is all part of a
bigger message that symbolizes something
deeper metaphorical meaning about all
the Angels religion and perhaps life as
we know it
[Music]
she was me
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
you